write down the move and then you have to
call the arbiter over and you say hey
i am going to make this move and then we
would have repeated the position three
times you can't just make the move
if you make the move and then claim
technically your opponent doesn't have
to
make the draw you can play on but
normally the players agree just three
times
he is making his move
okay so a moment of truth if magnus
retreats his knight we're about to see a
draw and there we have it yeah so napoli
actually he has to move his king forward
that's strictly the only move there we
go he stops the clock as if i mentioned
he doesn't make the move on the board he
stops it uh he tells the other it's
about to be three times and there we
have the handshake game four and by
between these two is another draw they
are still tied magnus carlsen and jana
pomnyachi magnus on his birthday with
the white pieces
this was not what he was hoping for
today definitely not
far from a success for the world
champion he walked into opening
preparation and the planet never had